PAUL SAXMAN: Hi, I'm Paul
Saxman, and I'm a Senior
Developer Advocate at Google.
In this tutorial, I'll be giving
you an overview of the
Google TV platform from a
developer's perspective.
Specifically, I'll cover why you
should consider developing
apps for connected TVs.
I'll talk about the main
features of Google TV that
developers should be
interested in.
And I'll tell you how to
get started building
apps for the platform.
It's a really great time for
developers to start building
apps for TVs, because it's
an emerging market.
There's less competition and
more room for creative ideas.
And there's still time for
developers to establish
themselves in the
smart TV space.
There are few statistics that
capture where the connected TV
market is going, which should
give you a sense of why you
should consider developing
apps for TVs.
The first statistic, that I
think is relevant, is that, in
the US, households have
an average of 2.5
people and 2.93 TV sets.
And the average number of TV
sets per household continues
to increase.
Whereas the average number
of people has
remained relatively constant.
What's interesting about this
statistic is that there are,
on average, more TVs than
people in US homes.
This also likely means that
people own more TVs than other
types of connected devices.
This is especially true for
personal devices, such as
laptops, smartphones,
and tablets.
Another interesting statistic
about TVs is that, in the US,
2.92 million people own TVs and
watch an average of five
hours of television per day.
Many people multicast
while watching TV.
So this can be shared time.
However, at five hours average
per day, television viewing is
likely the top leisure
activity in the US.
But what about connected TVs?
By the end of 2015, it's
projected that more than 500
million connected TVs
will have shipped.
And in 2015, alone, nearly half
of the flat panel TVs
sold will have some form of
internet connectivity.
And this 500 million cumulative
number does not
include TVs that are sold
without internet connectivity,
but that are connected to the
internet through a set-top
box, game console, media
PC, or the like.
The cumulative number of
smartphones sold reached
around 500 million at
the end of 2011.
But it's definitely worth noting
that smartphones have
been on the market for a number
of years, whereas the
connected TV market
is relatively new.
So why develop apps for TVs?
Well, a lot of people have
and watch televisions.
People watch television a lot.
And TVs are getting
smarter and better
connected every day.
Also, people love television.
And they want to interact with
it and it's content in more
rich and meaningful ways.
We created Google TV
with this in mind.
And we made it an open apps
platform, so that the
developers can use their
intelligence and creativity to
connect with users, when they're
in their homes and
looking to relax and
be entertained.
Google TV brings two open apps
platforms, Android and the
web, to the largest screen
and the best sound
system in most homes.
This is Android adapted for
the TV space, however.
So the platform includes support
for additional AV
codecs and formats, protocols,
and APIs that are
relevant for TVs.
Since Google TV is Android,
it's open for Android
developers to bring apps
to the living room.
In addition, Google TV includes
Google Chrome, so
developers that love HTML5
can bring their
apps to TVs as well.
Google TV is an open apps
platform, not a device.
However, there are devices
available or that are soon to
be released that
run Google TV.
On the left is Vizio stream
player and the Sony media
player, both of which can
be used to add Google TV
experience to HDTVs.
On the right is the LG G2 series
TV, which is a TV that
includes the Google
TV platform.
The Google TV homescreen, which
is the primary user
interface for the platform, has
been redesigned to be more
simple and intuitive and to take
advantage of several key
Android features.
The face in the background is
live TV, which the user can
bring to the foreground
quickly.
This area of the
homescreen also
supports Android app widgets.
Along the bottom of the home
screen is a customizable quick
launch bar.
Here, users have access to
status bar notifications sent
from apps, an all apps section,
the Google Play
Store, and Global
Quick Search.
Google TV has integrated Global
Quick Search, which
brings search results from a
number of sources to the user.
In this example, you can see
search results from the Google
TV programming guide, live
TV, and the web.
There are also search results
from apps here as well.
Any app that includes a Global
Search provider can publish
results to the user initiated
Global Searches on Google TV.
Google TV includes the
Google Play Store.
If you have an app that is
currently published in the
Google Play Store, it may
already be available for
Google TV users to install.
For the Google Play Store on
Google TV, we feature apps
that look and work
great on TVs.
To look great, apps should be
designed for the 10 foot or
three meter user experience.
This means that text in UI's
controls should be readable
from three meters away and
that users interact with
Google TV using handheld
remote controls.
Remote controls for the current
generation of devices
the support Google TV have a
number of similar features,
including full keyboards,
directional pads, pointing
devices, such as touchpads or
gyroscopic pointers, a search
key to access Global Quick
Search, media control keys,
and the Android buttons,
Back, Home, and Menu.
The directional pad or d-pad is
a very important feature of
the remote controls
for Google TV.
Most users prefer to use the
d-pad for navigation, so
developers should ensure
that their Google TV
apps support it.
Thankfully, the Android platform
includes support for
d-pad navigation with standard
interactive views.
Developers may need to add
d-pad support to customer
views, however.
To do so, they need to ensure
that their customer views are
focusable and that they
show navigation focus.
Google TV can also be controlled
with one or more
virtual input devices.
This is the Google TV remote
control app for Android, which
is available in the
Google Play store.
A version of this app is also
available for iOS devices.
These apps turn user's
smartphones and tablets into
Google TV universal remote
controls, allowing them to
interact with their TVs in
new and unique ways.
For example, these apps allow
users to search for content on
Google TV using voice input.
The technology behind these
virtual controllers is open
for developers to use, to build
their own second screen
apps for Google TV.
Imagine using your smartphone or
tablet as a game controller
or giving multiple TV viewers
a shared experience on a TV,
but allowing them to interact
individually with the TV using
apps on their own handheld
devices.
The idea of using multiple
screens in the living room is
relatively new.
But it's quickly gaining
popularity.
So now it's also a great time to
start building apps for the
second screen as well.
Now onto some lower level
technical details
about Google TV.
This is a table of the Android
screen sizes, densities, and
physical resolutions.
There's a lot of information
in this table.
But what's most important
are the two cells
highlighted in orange.
These are the Google TV screens,
which correspond to
720 and 1080 HDTV resolutions.
Google TV supports two pixel
densities, XHDPI and TVDPI,
which is pretty close to HDPI.
I To support both HD
resolutions, you generally
only need to include XHDPI
resources with your
application.
The platform will scale the
resources for TVDPI.
If you do the math, you'll
notice that the density
independent pixel resolutions,
for both screen sizes, works
out to 960 by 540.
Google TV is a large screen,
independent of the resolution.
It's not extra large, like Xoom
tablet, because TVs are
viewed from much further away.
It's all a matter
of perspective.
Google TV includes a content
provider, for retrieving a
list of TV channels that the
user has available, and
supports an Intent for changing
channels for the user.
If you want to use this content
provider, you must
include the READ CHANNELS
permission
in your apps manifest.
This content provider has the
names, numbers, and call signs
for the channels, as
well as the URI for
channel changing Intent.
Google TV also includes two
second screen services that
can be accessed on the
user's home network.
The first is for pairing
personal devices with Google
TV, so that the devices
can securely send
information to the TV.
The second is the Anymote
Protocol, which allows devices
to send key events, mouse
events, such as movement and
clicking, basic stream data, and
URIs for starting Intents.
Whichever app is in the
foreground will receive the
key and mouse events.
So you can use the Anymote
Protocol to build companion
apps for phones or tablets
that interact
with Google TV apps.
These protocols form the
foundation of the Google TV
multi screen experience.
Java and C++ libraries that
implement these protocols are
available online, open source,
so the developers don't need
to start from scratch when
building second screen apps
that integrate with Google TV.
The Google TV remote app for
Android, that I mentioned
earlier, uses these protocols
and is available,
open source, as well.
Due to the 16x9 aspect ratios
of HD televisions, a
horizontal, left to right layout
works better on Google
TV than the vertical, top to
bottom layout, that is
commonly used for phones
and tablet apps.
To help developers implement
a horizontal layout, we've
released a left navigation
bar Android library.
This library includes a class
that extends the Android
Action Bar Class, so that you
can use it exactly like you
would the Action Bar.
The only difference is that it
draws a cell vertically on the
left hand side of the display,
instead of at the top.
Google TV includes an Android
location provider, but
location works a little bit
differently on Google TV than
it does on Android phones
and tablets.
To access the location provider
on Google TV, you
must include the coarse location
permission in your
manifest, which is for non
precise coordinates.
And to retrieve a user's
location, you need to use the
static location provider.
The location that you get from
the Location Manager is only
accurate to the postal
code level.
Users are asked to enter their
postal codes, when configuring
Google TV for the first time,
and they can reenter the
information, at any time, using
the system settings.
You should, therefore, only use
the postal code portion of
the address associated with the
coordinates returned from
the location provider.
To start developing apps for
Google TV, you'll need to
install the Android SDK Tools.
And if you'll be using the
Eclipse IDE for development,
which is recommended,
you'll need the
ADT plug-in for Eclipse.
Once you have the SDK Tools
installed, you can run the
Android SDK Manager and install
the Android 3.1 SDK
package for developing
Google TV apps.
Documentation for installing
and using the development
tools can be found on the
Android developer website at
developer.android.com/sdk.
For testing your app, the
Android SDK Tools includes a
hardware accelerated emulator,
that you can use in
conjunction with the Google TV
add-on that is part of the
Android 3.1 SDK package.
It can also help to use a
real device for testing
apps for Google TV.
An Android tablet, in landscape
mode, with a USB or
Bluetooth keyboard attached,
will allow you to test your
layouts in d-pad navigation.
However, you should definitely
consider getting a Google TV
device for development.
It could definitely make the
difference between building a
good app and a great app.
And finally, the Google TVs
developer site is the best
place to go to get started
with building
apps for Google TV.
Be sure to visit the site at
developers.google.com/tv
before you dive into coding.
This site includes
documentation, design
guidelines, community resources,
and sample code
that should definitely help
you build your app.
And that's everything
for this tutorial.
If you have any questions,
please feel free to reach out
to the Google TV team
on Google+.
Our Google+ page is Google
TV Developers.
Thanks for watching.